la mode peut-elle changer le monde vous
me direz la mode c'est la légèreté la
futilité le plaisir on se demande bien
comment la mode pourrait changer le
monde
pourtant la mode elle a toujours
influencé le monde vous avez sur cette
première image une chaussure prix
historique a été trouvé en arménie qui
datent de moins six ans avant
jésus-christ et depuis l'aube de
l'humanité évidemment se vêtir a été un
besoin fondamental
on a d'abord cherché dans son entourage
proche des matériaux qu'on pouvait
utiliser pour confectionner des
vêtements mais très rapidement la mode
est devenu un acte culturel puisque on a
ajouté des ornements selon son steak
selon sa communauté selon son pays
d'appartenance très rapidement les
hommes se sont impayés de manière
différenciée
on a également fait du commerce avec la
mode la carte que vous avez là c'est
celle de la route de la soie la route de
la soie c'est une route qui datent de
moins de cent ans avant jésus-christ et
qui a été qui reliait donc la chine et
d'autres pays et qui a été créée par la
dynastie and en chine justement et cette
route
aujourd'hui encore elle a à la fois
tracé les contours d'un commerce
international mais aussi elle a défini
des équilibres géopolitiques on retrouve
dans des dents les cartes actuelles la
mode
elle a également évidemment été à la
pointe je dirais de la révolution
industrielle vous savez la révolution
industrielle au 19e siècle on transforme
l'économie puisque on passe d'une
économie vivrières d'une économie on a
une proton industrie des petits ateliers
à une économie ont réuni l'appareil
productif même endroit pour optimiser la
fabrication en grande bretagne et en
france c'est dans l'industrie textile
que s'exprime le plus cette révolution
industrielle puisqu'on a grâce à des
progrès technique / fois par cinq voire
par mille le temps dont on avait besoin
pour faire cette certaines opérations
pour réaliser des vêtements
on a aussi repenser l'organisation du
travail et plus encore on a transformé
des territoires entiers la photo que
vous avez là c'est une photo de roubaix
c'est la vie dont je suis originaire et
cette ville c'est une ville champignon
qui a été totalement aménagé autour de
l'industrie textile
les gens sont venus de partout dans le
monde pour y travailler et toute la
ville était structurée autour de cette
activité
donc la mode a changé des territoires et
à changer une économie et puis la
dernière photo ces salles diffusant
laurent vous avez après la seconde
guerre mondiale la démocratisation du
prêt-à-porter mais aussi l'arrivée de
créateurs qui sont devenus des stars
littéralement et qui ont finalement
rendu publique leur processus de
création et qui ont transformé le
vêtement qui en ont fait un acte
politique
un acte de société quand ils sont alors
en 1967 fait le smoking par exemple eh
bien c'est clairement pour affirmer une
transformation dans les rapports de
genre dans les rapports entre les hommes
et les femmes dans le rôle des femmes
dans la société
sachant que ce n'est qu'en 2012 qui a
été officiellement abrogé le décret qui
interdisait le port du pantalon pour les
femmes
donc la mode à l' influence le monde et
l'influencent aussi et elle transforme
notre monde puisque la mode
l'industrie de la mode vous quitte une
période de black friday
vous le voyez c'est un emblème
aujourd'hui de cette société de
consommation contre connaît depuis
l'après guerre c'est une société dans
laquelle on consomme au delà de ses
besoins de manière parfois frénétiques
voir aliénante des produits dont on ne
connaît même pas l'origine et
l'industrie de la mode a été en pointe
dans ce modèle est là bien sûr choisi
l'obsolescence des tendances comme un
levier pour nous amener à consommer
toujours plus au delà de nos besoins et
grâce justement à cette capacité qu'a la
mode de nous inspirer l'envi profonde
d'avoir des choses et bien elle a pu
nous proposer les tendances toujours
plus rapide elle s'est affranchie des
saisons adieu le printemps et l'été et
l'automne et l'hiver bonjour le réassort
permanent certaines enseignes de mode
propose jusqu'à 40000 modèles par an de
vêtements différents
et puis évidemment je vais mentionné
grâce aux prix bas et à la course aux
prix bas aux soldes permanentes aux
opérations spéciales ou journée
privilèges on a tout le temps le souhait
où on est tout le temps sollicités
pour y retourner toujours plus toujours
moins cher et pour faire toujours moins
cher et bien on a sous traité
on a décidé de faire appel à des pays la
régulation du droit du travail n'était
pas du tout aux exigeantes et ça a
conduit à une transformation aussi de la
façon dont on consommer et de la façon
dont ont commercé le vêtement 70%
aujourd'hui des vêtements qui sont
achetés en europe proviennent d'asie du
sud-est sa d'autres conséquences
évidemment sur mon territoire qui ne
faisait essentiellement que la
confection textile et de la fabrication
textile et bien ça a entraîné un chômage
de masse
les gens qui étaient venus de partout
dans le monde pour travailler la voix se
sont retrouvés avec des taux de chômage
de plus de 50% dans certains quartiers
et à l'autre bout du monde la photo que
vous avez l'acsl durana plaza en 2013
une usine s'effondre faisant plus de
1000 morts justement parce qu'on avait
aucune garantie sur la sécurité et les
conditions de travail des personnes qui
confectionnait nos vêtements que nous
achetions pendant le black friday
la dernière image elle illustre aussi
comment l'industrie de la mode nous met
dans cette frénésie de la possession et
puis elle nous met aussi dans une image
décore dans une diktat des corps souvent
celui de la maigreur dans une finalement
une forme d'aliénation dont j'ai déjà
parlé
et puis bien sûr ce que je viens de
mentionner c'est important mais il ya un
élément dans l'industrie de la mode qui
me semble encore plus déterminant c'est
le poids qu'il a dans les pollutions
mondiale aujourd'hui l'industrie de la
mode la mode est considérée comme une
des industries les plus polluantes au
monde
elle émet plus de gaz à effet de serre
que le transport aérien et le transport
maritime international confondues elle
est la troisième consommatrices d eau
d'irrigation dans le monde pour la
culture du coton
seul on utilise 25 % des pesticides du
monde
les fibres les plus utilisés aujourd'hui
dans la dans la confection et dans les
vêtements qui nous sont proposées ce
sont les cotons le coteau et le
polyester le polyester skin fibres
synthétiques
chaque lavage allumé défi des micros au
plastique qui se retrouvent dans les
océans
on estime que cela représente 50
milliards de bouteilles en plastique
dans les océans
la can et qui se retrouve de suite à
l'utilisation et au lavage des vêtements
on pourrait continuer je dirais à
décrire cette situation encore longtemps
je voulais juste vous citer un chiffre
celui de la situation de la chine 70%
des autres surfaces en chine sont
considérés comme polluées par les
colorants textile donc oui la mode
change le monde
elle transforme son visage mais la mode
elle a un atout formidable c'est une
industrie créative une industrie du sens
on s'habille pas simplement par
fonctionnalités je les dis on s'habille
aussi parce qu'on veut communiquer une
identité c'est un moyen de communication
non verbale est donc finalement cette
créativité qu'à la mode elle peut aussi
l'aider à changer plus vite et inspiré
des changements fondamentaux dans la
société
ça c'est la situation actuelle elle est
pas très enviable et je suis une
parenthèse en plus elle n'est pas
durable y compris du point de vue
économique puisque par exemple le marché
de l'habillement français a perdu 15% de
sa valeur en disant mon inquiétude
aujourd'hui c'est que l'industrie de la
confection qui a connu de grandes
difficultés en france et bien
aujourd'hui ce soit l'industrie de la
distribution
l'économie de la distribution dont les
sièges sont dans ma région à roubaix où
je suis toujours un qui vont connaître
ces difficultés là puisque aujourd'hui
on achète moins de vêtements neufs et
que forcément cette crise de sens cette
saturation du marché
elle va elle va forcément amener des
évolutions et des évolutions dont les
premières victimes seront probablement
les salariés ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de bagages aussi comme les vendeurs dans
les magasins vous regardez nos
centres-villes aujourd'hui là où il y
avait les cellules commerciales avec des
magasins de vêtements souvent on trouve
des cellules vides
la créativité peut changer un peu changé
la mode est inspiré des changements dans
le monde d'abord le premier levier
severus cette créativité peut être mise
au service de l'échonova sion échos
innover ça veut dire déjà se demander si
je dois pas prélever de ressources
naturelles nouvelle dans un monde fini
si je ne dois pas émettre de polluants
supplémentaires dans un monde fille
qu'est-ce que je peux faire utiliser des
matières recyclées et il ya suffisamment
de textile à recycler qu'on a gaspillé
parce qu'ils ont été invendus
invendable que ce sont des chutes voir
des vêtements que nous avons dans notre
caca pas la carte parenthèse un vêtement
sur deux dans notre blatter nous ne
portons pas eh bien ces matières elles
peuvent devenir de nouvelles matières
premières pour faire des produits de
mode et habillement deuxième matière
première ce sont les déchets issus
d'autres industries on sait faire de la
viscose avec deux l'éplucheur d'orange
on sait faire aussi du cuir avec des
feuilles d'ananas on peut utiliser
aujourd'hui des tas de produits qui sont
issus d'autres secteurs pour faire des
produits textiles et les recycler à
l'infini
la basket que vous avez là c'est une
basket qui est fait à partir de
plastique des océans c'est une marque de
sneakers
aujourd'hui cette basket c'est une
association qui collecte les télés les
plastiques des océans l'association
parler fort dit aussi lente et elle est
recyclable en 2022 elle sera recyclable
à l'infini
il faut penser dès le début du produit à
son réemploi la réparabilité sa
recyclabilité si un produit que je sors
ne peut pas être réutilisés ne peut pas
être réemployés ne peut pas être
transformés je ne le fait pas
aujourd'hui c'est pas recyclés
massivement les textiles parce qu'il ya
des mecs matière entre du coton et du
polyester par exemple donc tout ceci
peut être transformé par l'innovation
des circuits courts rapprocher le lieu
de fabrication du lieu de consommation
ça semble évident à jill et ses
composants parcours 65 mille kilomètres
est-ce que c'est tout à fait acceptable
aujourd'hui fabriquées sans chute avec
la conception 3d on sait fabriquer des
produits en évitant d'avoir des chutes
de production au moment de la découpe
des tissus est fabriqué à la demande
on croule sous les invendus les
invendables le surstocks les soldes pour
écouler tout cela est donc c'est grâce
aux outils digitaux on est capable
aujourd'hui de faire du réassort
automatique mais pas simplement depuis
l'entrepôt où le vêtement attend d'être
envoyé en magasin mais depuis la
confection évidemment ça demande de
rapprocher le lieu de confection lieux
de distribution le deuxième levier c'est
de changer le métier de ce qu'est un
marque ou une enseigne marque ou une
enseigne son sujet demain ne doit plus
être dans notre vision d'avenir de
vendre des abymes et d'habiller les
champs quand on se dit que mon sujet
mon objet
tif c'est d'habiller des gens mon
business ça veut dire que mon objectif
sera d'abord de les conseiller pour que
le vêtement qu'ils achètent ils le
portent effectivement ça peut être aussi
de leur proposer des services de
réparation de services de location des
services de revente de seconde main tout
est possible dans cet univers de
nouvelles façons d'aborder le métier
et puis il ya un dixième dernier sujet
que j'ai déjà évoqué c'est cette
créativité elle a aussi pour rôle
d'inspirer d'inspirer des changements
l'âme l'industrie de la mode peut
proposer aujourd'hui des vêtements qui
sont davantage adapté à nouveau mode de
vie si on veut mobilité et respectueuse
de l'environnement il faut des modes
doux il faut du vélo il faut par exemple
justement transformer les vêtements pour
qu'il soit adapté à ces nouveaux modes
de vie il faut aussi dans l'histoire que
raconte les marques et les enseignes
qu'elle puisse raconter cette histoire
que nous vivons collectivement qui est
celle de devoir être des acteurs de la
régénération de la planète et ça je
pense que c'est un message fort que les
consommateurs peuvent comprendre alors
agir aujourd'hui
moi c'est ce que j'essaye de faire
d'abord j'ai écrit un livre qui fait un
peu le point sur tout ce que je viens de
vous raconter parce que je pense que il
fallait comprendre avant d'agir
comprendre l'étendue de la situation les
leviers par lesquels on en était arrivé
là c'est important parce que agir sans
comprendre ces s'agite et donc vous avez
très envie de passer du temps et j'y ai
passé du temps pour analyser vraiment le
processus par lequel cette industrie
s'était transformée pour arriver à cette
situation là aujourd'hui
et ensuite on a lancé à plusieurs dans
une association qui s'appelle nord crée
un un forum des solutions alors au
départ quand on la lance et on pensait
pas que tout le monde répondrai présent
et en fait on a quasiment toutes les
grandes entreprises françaises qui
viennent à ce forum des solutions pour
voir tout ce qui peut exister
j'ai évoqué certains exemples delà des
produits recyclables
nouvelle façon de vendre des vêtements
et il réunit toutes ces entreprises mais
aussi les jeunes startups les jeunes
créateurs parce qu'ils sont très
nombreux à s'engager aujourd'hui il
réunit aussi des experts qui travaillent
sur les textiles de demain et puis la
dernière chose c'est qu'on s'est divorcé
bien d'expliquer ce qu'il faut faire
mais ce serait bien de le démontrer et
donc on a monté un atelier qui s'appelle
plateau fertile et qui propose
aujourd'hui de la confection à partir de
chutes d'invendus et qui sont remis dans
le circuit de distribution des marques
l'idée c'est de faire des circuits
courts en boucle fermée sur un
territoire et en occurrence il
évidemment à roubaix alors et vous dans
cette histoire moi je crois que chacun
peut s'engager dans cette dans cette
action évidemment si vous aimez la mode
n'hésitez pas à entreprendre
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya plein de
nouveaux métiers nouvelles entreprises à
créer dans ce domaine mais vous pouvez
aussi simplement lorsque vous achetez
vos vêtements vous demandez qui les a
faits et dans quelles conditions
et si une marque ou une enseigne n'est
pas capable de vous expliquer la
traçabilité datant toute traçabilité en
toute transparence comment d'où viennent
ces vêtements
il y a un problème est peut-être il faut
passer son chemin et puis il ya une
action encore plus simple qui n'est même
pas celle une action de résistance à la
frénésie mais une action qui peut vous
faire plaisir celle de trier son placard
et de se demander dans mon placard de
quoi j'ai vraiment besoin ce que j'aime
ce qui nous rend meilleurs plus beaux
ceux qui communiquent davantage sur ce
que je suis au près des autres et
privilégier ses vêtements et ensuite
bien sûr le second main mes marques
engagées
tout ce qui peut contribuer à cette
régénération
alors oui moi je crois que l'industrie
de la mode et la mode peut changer le
monde dans toutes ses dimensions dans ce
qu'elle inspirait dans ce qu'elle fait
et elle a besoin de tous et de toutes
pour pouvoir y arriver et vous pouvez en
être des acteurs
[Applaudissements]